okay so here's the issue everyone's
saying like you missed storytelling the
episode storytelling the truth is that
we did shoot it we actually shot it when
Brandon was here as well and we have Rob
and Jason everything but what I imported
everything somehow that didn't get
imported so that's gone forever I look
for it so sorry guys but at the same
time
ya might as well give you just my
general thought I'd you know still do a
V long guy cuz I remember being pretty
funny this is an episode where you got
Jake is not feeling well and he asked
for him to tell him a story but it was
really complicated like somehow he has
to make up a story that's also true but
it's an exciting true story that
happened to him and it's just Jake's too
man so Finn decides okay I'm gonna go
and make you the best story to ever tell
you and so he goes out he tries to
create all these stories and by doing so
he's like making things really worse for
a lot of people or at least it appears
like he's trying to get like these two
animals together that shouldn't belong
together and you know that they hate
each other even more now or at least one
hates the other and then like he tries
to go like I said just get adventures
going and we see the snail ant in great
detail this time and just everything's
going wrong until finally the woods like
just rebel against him and they're
saying no we're we're tired of you
screwing things up and they're they're
about to kill him um it gets kind of
grim actually yeah but he points out
that hey I actually kind of helped you
guys when you think about it like he was
talking about this one bear who is over
parenting or under parenting I forget
exactly how it worked out like the other
bears like really violent or it was
really nuts and a lot of members in yeah
yeah okay and actually the one thing I
really enjoy is that the two animals he
tries to force together one has the hots
for the other and the other doesn't and
Finn says something that I think it's
really important for relationships which
I it's most adults know this but
nevertheless it's still good to you know
enforce on kids is that you know if you
like someone but that someone doesn't
like you
yep that's you stop it's a two-way
street I think a lot of people I don't
know if it specifically a male or female
thing but a lot of people going into you
know looking for a mate and stuff like
that think like well if I try harder if
I'm even more charming or if I'm even
more successful if I'm even more
good-looking whatever then that should
be good and I should get that person
stuff that two-way street you know
that's how it works and I like that he
says look and I think it's like a fox or
something you know you can't win her you
know this just isn't the way it's gonna
go she's not interested in you you know
that's the big thing it's not that
you're not good enough it's just that
you're not compatible you're just not
into each other so I like that IV it's
just a little thing but Alamut you still
be surprised like how many like these
lovely romantic comedies they're always
like oh the boy tried to go up to the
girl the girls not interest so the boy
tries harder or embarrasses himself or
just keeps going and that wins her over
instead of it's like no that's creepy
you know that's that's not good you know
the notebook and big fish is stuff I
love big fish and that's but that's a
fairy tale even so like this is you know
a tall tale it's based on myth and fairy
tales and stuff like that so that's not
reality so I like that actually
Adventure Time let's show intended for
kids actually gets the idea of
relationships better than most Julia
Roberts romantic comedies do so all
right yeah so you got that uh oh my god
this hilarious scene where you know he's
trying to teach everyone to be okay with
themselves and this cow has a bag over
her otter and said take that bag off
you're beautiful the way you are and she
takes it off and it's just I gave and
explained it it looks like a nut sack
with a smiley face and it's just the
last thing you expect to see there you
just go
your guy repulsed him laughing at the
same time cuz it's just the last thing
you expected he says I put that back on
no that's disgusting
so it did backtrack a little bit their
morale but still made the world's just
not ready for an utter that utterly
disgusting but maybe it will be maybe we
will learn as a species I did grace so
and he goes back in and he tells the
story and it's it was good it was a
really good episode I am I don't have
someone to bounce information off of and
like it's usually not that great on this
on my own but at least adventure time
but it was good it had a lot of funny
stuff in it and I I like that from the
beginning of it you can't quite
guess what direction it's going or even
what its gonna sort of come around to so
I'll I kind of like that too and yeah I
get real short one this time but like I
said sorry I taped over the last one um
will not happen again hopefully
so half scouts honor I was never a scout
but the two-finger honor swear whatever
take